okay new 15-minute game has started
I played see four different if I cut cut
white again somehow I always get white
here so what does I could play neither
three for change and let's see what he
comes up with is six quite a flexible
move I'd like to check where were the
opponent is from from from Nigeria this
is round okay
see for let's play let's play g3 maybe
try Kings Indian text set up alright I
don't think I've played played this yet
and commentary games usually I play c4d
for now for the Catalan but let's for a
change dryer Kings Indian attack setup
it's always interesting to to play for
change ok c6 is somewhat strange some
well it's not the most useful moves here
just c5 would be able to normal
c6 is quite often played once the bishop
is out of the pawn chain on g4 f5 or h7
that let's say first develop the bishop
then play it safe then play c6 it's a
very solid after the the bishop is out
of the pawn chain but c6 just to move
that that hinders the bishop
yeah h6 I'm not sure towards the point
of this move okay let's just strength
strengthen the position a bit further
usual Kings Indian attack setup inverse
e 5 and I intend to play this in the
next move I just want to see what is
doing next
haha yeah this is really bizarre
or if nothing else I can play to stage
three and he needs to return to f6 okay
let's keep it simple
now e5 maybe okay
the typical movie another one to prepare
Bishop f4 and now he's playing c5 now
I've got the normal position was just a
couple of extra moves yes one one idea
that black might try to play play f6
trying to get rid of the five pawn of
course it's weakening e6 any five and so
on but it's about the only idea to get a
little bit of active play I could also
think about playing c4 here this is
maybe possible now with all the extra
moves c4 would hinder any black young
Queen side counter play also normal
would be aged for the typical system
museum okay let's pledge form
yeah he went for f6
yeah okay let's just take it
we should we have six maybe an idea yeah
okay so what now
I've got decent control over 85 but not
not great control now the ideas should
be h3 but then he might have e5 some
kind of strange pawn sacrifice don't
want to deal with this actually
yeah let's occupy this first if you play
some okay we should be six I wanted to
play night h2
okay I'm just one temple shot of
covering the square with the night 9h to
f3 for instance maybe Bishop h3 is an
idea let's say he takes on e5 rook takes
e5 and then I could I could always play
Queen e2 covering e5 if he texted and
your sex is just threatened yeah this
looks like a good idea one issue was the
g4 square let's say I would have played
instead of Bishop h3 Queen e2 he might
take you five Queen e5 Knight g4 and f2
is hanging twice and now I can I can
just recapture with rook and if you yeah
he plays this I should I should have
Queen e2 he cannot attack the rook with
97 because his six is hanging multiple
times our came just one second Queen e2
he might have night to Eve form
hmm that's a nice trip really 2294
amazing the kind of stuff that sometimes
works a chest okay so maybe I need to
play a for him don't want to really okay
let's say okay let's say quickly Queenie
- and all night before then f-for
yeah this is better any normal okay
normal moving to this kind of offices of
course justjust better for white I think
just yeah this is looking really nice
doll
okay now trying to get the night
involved on g4 or f3 really ugly
position for black ok let's try a 94 get
rid of the last defender of the e5
square well that's a possible defender
if the Knights get off then I have let's
say eternal pressure on e6 and so just
terrible
and yet black doesn't have anything
special 'i'm not just needs to sit and
wait okay i take on f6 now can you take
with the palm yeah maybe
can of course the knight would also be a
nice piece on only five some move like
ruby three is not not ridiculous okay
let's check first taking on f6 phone
takes yeah but I don't have anything
anything directly
okay I don't see anything else at at the
moment
okay this is all these twins material
you can just take this heaven okay let's
grab let's grab the material just the
cleanest solution your six just drops
off now and this is an exchange
yeah we got the seventh always nice to
have
okay just try keep it simple exchange
Queens and and win this endgame
okay but okay I also have rook g6 now
yeah he takes on f - It's Made in
Toulouse oh so ambitious the knight
takes on f2 I take g7 then h7 rook h7
checking g8 and rookie - g7 mate so I
guess he has to return to have six and
give me all kinds of quads on the
seventh ring not actually resigned time
alone does it have fun really really
okay
he lost me too to give this checked out
it's okay
checkmate
yes was somewhat weird flame I'm like
starting with snide g4 incoming
challenge oops
he actually challenged me for a rematch
with regular 50-minute game let's just
check just check Oakley a.m. yeah here
here here thought that maybe Bishop f6
would be at least something to consider
Bishop f6 Ruby 6 sometimes black get
some compensation for this pawn but also
b2 is maybe hanging at some point maybe
an idea because while the bishop on f6
just does more - to protect e5 but he
took took with this night and now I are
getting fine he also Bishop e6 comes
into consideration
yeah this nozzle is nice for wide I
think this should be just just just a
steady stable advantage he cannot really
gain control over the five square and
they just have this pressure on these
six not sure maybe the round here I
could have done something better but
yeah would be three it's not I don't
know yeah maybe it's okay maybe it's
okay
it keeps a huge advantage of course but
it's not really the most aggressive move
computer computer give Queen e3 I know a
sentence move Queen e3 what's the idea
Queen here for something well I like
trophy three it's not better to get the
Knight to e5 while Adam exchange so that
it becomes a completely stable advantage
against e6 pawn so and this just let out
blue awesome material yeah so pretty
straightforward wouldn't here for the
last game of the day I think I like to
do the 15-minute games unless yeah and
it says stressful for the commentator
you got some more time to to to explain
various points in the game so I'm very
much welcoming your feedback on on the
15-minute format I'd like to do this
occasionally it's very comfortable for
me to do instead of the five minute
games they're quite often I don't think
I have enough time to really explain
properly what what's going on so yeah
that's just hear your opinions about
this format yeah thanks for watching and
I guess I'll do some some more tomorrow
I'm having a couple of days off from
work so I've got time to to do videos
and yeah that's uh let's see I felt do
some some more tomorrow see ya